alors en corée du sud de l'année 2017 a
commencé comme s'était terminée 2016
c'était devant un chaos politique avec
des manifestations pour réclamer la
démission de la présidente qui est
accusé entre autres de d'abus de pouvoir
de corruption et dont la destitution
avait été votée par le parlement en
décembre dernier alors en asie en 2017
on va surveiller non seulement ce qui se
passe du côté politique les tensions
politiques mais aussi des tensions
sécuritaires
on pense entre autres à la corée du nord
qui affirmait elle être capable bientôt
de pouvoir lancer des missiles
balistiques intercontinentaux aussi des
tensions économiques très possible on
pense par exemple à la volonté du
président américain nouvellement élu
donald trump déposer des frais de douane
exorbitants aux produits qui sont
fabriqués en chine justement on peut se
demander jusqu'où va aller ce froid qui
semble s'être abattue hafsi rapidement
entre washington avant même l'arrivée de
donald trump à la maison blanche
ce froid entre washington et la china et
la chine qui a été régulièrement visé
par les républicains durant sa course à
la maison blanche
et depuis même son élection on se
rappelle que son échange téléphonique
avec la présidente de taiwan taiwan une
île considérée comme une partie
intégrale de la chine unique et bien ça
a déplu aux autorités chinoises
et on pourrait voir aussi bouger un peu
de mouvement dans le jeu des alliances
en asie dans les prochains mois entre
autres avec la mort annoncée du
partenariat trans pacifique dont étaient
exclus la chine mais qui était considéré
comme une pièce maîtresse de
l'administration obama pour recentrer la
politique américaine étrangères dans la
région et aussi avec ce rapprochement
qu'on a vues entre le président des
philippines et la chine donc rodrigo du
terreau t qui fait sourciller souvent
les manchettes aussi avec sa lutte
antidrogue sanglante et très musclé dont
beaucoup d'enjeux politiques économiques
sociaux environnementaux mais aussi
sportif parce que en février ce sera le
début du compte à rebours un an
avant la tenue des jeux d'hiver en corée
du sud à conques chang et savate en
quelque sorte le lancement d'une série
olympique en asie parce qu'en 2020 on va
avoir les jeux olympiques au japon et en
2022 en chine